[Music]
for us it kind of is extraordinary
because it's the one that keeps us alive
so it's sort of important in that sense
um but one of the one of the probably
the biggest lesson that's come out of
astronomy in the last 500 years is the
fact that we're really nothing special
you know we used to think that the earth
was the center of the universe and then
actually we discovered it isn't the sun
is is the center of the solar system at
least then for a while we thought well
maybe the sun's the center of the
universe and then we discovered actually
no the sun's in the boring suburbs of
the galaxy and so on so one of the
things sort of slightly depressing
lessons of astronomy is we're really
nothing special
and in that sense i suppose it really
shouldn't come as a surprise that the
sun's nothing special either it's just
like many billions of other stars
well based on all the stars we've been
able to measure their masses their
luminosities their
metallicities properties like that it
tends to fall somewhere in the middle of
the distribution so it's typical there's
a lot more of those than there are of
say the really big massive stars well
there are symbols for all the major
bodies in our own solar system and some
of them come out of directly out of the
sort of greek and roman mythology one of
the useful symbols that we use is the
symbol that represents the sun because
the sun is one of our near benchmarks
for something that's big something
that's massive
so sometimes when we talk about the mass
of large astronomical objects we simply
add up how many masses of the sun it
would take to make that object so here i
mean one of the things that you often
put kind of at the end of a textbook is
just a bunch of useful numbers and one
of the the
the sets of numbers that astronomers use
all the time are things relating to the
sun so for example we often weigh things
in in units of the mass of the sun so
there's the mass of the sun quoted to
the number of significant figures we
know it so it's about 2 times 10 to the
32 with 30 zeros after it kilograms
here's the radius of the sun
which is about 700 million meters and
there's the luminosity of the sun which
is 3 times 10 to the 26 so 3 with 26
zeros after it watts so that means if
you look in a textbook and you see a
number you see 10 000 and next to it you
see a big m with this symbol a circle
with a dot in it that means that
whatever they're talking about weighs 10
000 times the mass of our sun so the
symbol that we use is this little circle
with a dot in the middle of it which
astronomers tend to refer to as odot
which is just a little suffix that comes
after all these things
a lot of times people ask me what's the
closest star in the universe and i say
well the sun
it's kind of easily forgotten that the
star that our sun is actually a star is
it
a typical star
well no because we live around it um but
compared to all the other stars we've
actually observed it is typical it
really it's about as bog standard as you
can get yeah i mean it's a
stars you know the range of masses of
stars for example they tend to go from
about a tenth the mass of the sun up to
maybe
100 times the mass of the sun that's a
really massive star um so the sun's sort
of right in the middle there somewhere
there are some that are a bit less
massive there's some the more massive
there are some the brighter there are
some that are fainter but it really is
pretty typical
so a star is a big
ball of
nuclear fusion there's lots of gases
that are condensed in the center nuclear
reactions happen and that's where
chemical elements are created so that's
where you build your
carbon and your bigger elements and fill
up the periodic table there and there
are astronomers who spend their entire
career studying the sun
and the reason why they do it is partly
because actually we have a sort of
vested interest in knowing what the sun
is going to do if the sun's going to go
out it will be useful to know about it
it isn't i hasten to point out when you
have these nuclear reactions they
actually release little bits of energy
photons and those photons get bounced
around on the inside for millions and
millions of years until they happen to
get to
whatever you loosely define as the
surface of your star and then off they
go on their little path so from our sun
once a photon escapes it actually takes
eight minutes to get to us on earth but
in terms of a bigger picture um
astronomers are just interested in the
sun just because it's a typical star it
just happens to be one that's
conveniently close
in physical size the sun is
very big something like 700 000
kilometers i don't know you can take
100 earths and line them up next to each
other across the diameter of the sun so
it's it's huge so if you want to learn
something about the sort of the generic
properties of stars
then the sun is a very good example just
because it's right nearby and we can
study it in excruciating detail we can
learn a whole lot more about the sun
than we can about any other star
when when we see solar flares and
prominences from the surface of the sun
you can fit
say the entire earth inside of those
prominences so the whole sun is just
massive you can i mean you need very
specialized equipment you really
absolutely do not want to go staring at
the sun
and you absolutely don't want to look
through a telescope or a pair binoculars
at the sun you can really do your eyes
permanent damage that way so don't do it
but with the appropriate equipment you
really can so we use you know you never
look directly at the sun but astronomers
use detectors which are capable of
dealing with those incredibly high light
levels without getting damaged the way i
would
and can actually record enormous amounts
of information about the sun that we
really can't see in any other style
completely coincidental that
in our sky when we look out from the
earth the sun our sun and our moon
look to be exactly the same size so when
the moon crosses in front of the sun we
see a solar eclipse it's completely
coincidental it could be that maybe if
the moon was a little farther away then
it would look a lot smaller and then we
wouldn't see a total solar eclipse